hi I'm Shelby Harris I'm here with
bleacher report and I'm playing start
[ __ ] I'm going to be giving a topic and
I'm going to have to start one bench one
and cut one so I'm gonna start remember
the titans
that's an easy one one of my favorite
ones and then I'm a bench Friday Night
Lights and considering I've never seen
Rudy I'm a credit never seen movie
before one of my favorite scenes you
know when the linebacker got hurt when
ha the team like rallied behind him
that's just it shows the true meaning of
being on a team and not just three
special alright let's go
i'ma start totally I think I said that's
huge and I'd be cool like to be able to
read whose minds
that'd be awesome I would have the bench
super speed
because I'm obviously a big defensive
lineman I'm not the fastest but then I
just got to cut you know superhuman
strength I think that uh you can live
with the other two without the third I
always want to know what - thinking
because I'm telling that man he's a
different type of man so you know he
must have some crazy thoughts alright I
gotta start suing the Williams I feel
like you know man or woman she's one of
the best athletes out there just what
she did after having a child and coming
back in and dominating the sport again
you know you gotta commend her I've got
the bench
Tiger Woods I really feel like you know
coming back after that whole controversy
and and with his knees he backs and
everything just coming back and winning
the Masters at one time that was a huge
moment and you know I just feel like
that was special and then you know
unfortunately you gotta cut Tom Brady
and it makes it easier cuz he's a
football player but you know honestly
just you know I just feel like the feats
are those other two are just I look at
those differently just because I played
football but I feel like those are just
so remarkable and what they've done oh
okay wings I'm starting love wings I'm a
big wing guy and then I'm and then I'm a
bench pizza and then I don't think I've
ever had seven later dude honest it
sounds tasty it sounds like someone will
get to talk about but you know I would
say yeah I love my wings I love pizza
and you know suddenly it did we just
gotta go so if we're talking like spicy
wings I like blue cheese you know the
buffalo the Caribbean jerks the mango
hoppin euros those but we're talking you
know garlic parmesan you gotta go ranch
okay I got a start get rich or die
trying' I feel like that that I could
play that one from start to finish and
and nothing but heat right there I'm
telling you and then I'm gonna have to
bench the car III am I really uh you
know I remember growing up on that day
went hard but then you know I'm
fortunate to cut the blueprint I'm not
really the biggest jay-z fan you know
but uh
I still like some of the songs on it but
definitely not as much as the other two
all right well you know I feel like you
got to start Beyonce I feel like that
was a great performance
I enjoyed Beyonce my wife enjoys be
outside so we enjoy being we enjoy be
outside you know I'm gonna have the
bench the end of Jackson that was an
epic performance you know just that
something that everyone's been talking
about for 10 years plus you know so that
was that was huge and then you know
unfortunately got a cut Katy Perry I
love caper I think she's a great you
know singer and performer but you know
it's just those other two just you know
remarkable I'm Shelby Harris and I just
played start binge cut